[Música]
a mesma dificuldade o meu deus do céu tá
aqui em síntese se eu vou deixar de
existir
[Música]
bom eu usei essa música do caetano
porque eu quatro parentes na minha fala
ela fala da cajuína que é um produto
como dna 100% tendência agora a gasolina
está inscrita como patrimônio imaterial
brasileiro
isso é uma prova de que as coisas estão
mudando em que a gente está começando a
olhar para o nosso umbigo e tem valor
então daqui pra frente sejamos doces e
transparentes como a cajuína é é dessa
frase do caetano essa música e lançou em
79 em homenagem por quatro neto o poeta
piauiense envolve o começo e fala essa
frase sempre teve na minha cabeça quando
lançado e nunca consegui entender porque
não tinha material para entender a
profundidade assistencialista que está
contida nessa frase e da importância que
a gente se colocar num reduto onde
olhando de um lado a gente como encontra
o passado e olhando um outro agente
encontra o futuro
de um lado temos o futuro é impreciso
incerto duvidoso e de um outro lado a
gente tem o passado pontual é preciso e
orientando a partir dele toda a nossa
trajetória e eu proponho nessa conversa
que eu espero espero que acaba em dez
minutos eu tô aqui me tremendo efe a
gente volte a olhar para esse passado
com intuito de entender melhor as nossas
origens e buscar nesse passado é uma
gama de sentimentos que foi o que eu
encontrei quando resolvi olhar no mês
passado
eu sei que aqui é eu tenho certeza que
posso encontrar pessoas que tenham um
passado muito recente no interior
essa viagem que eu proponho é o interior
dos ambientes decorados que os
arquitetos normalmente preparam pra
vocês eu proponho uma busca interna uma
viagem interna de cada um em busca
daquilo que falta coisa o marcelo macedo
falou de que a gente precisa voltar por
todos as nossas atenções para o próximo
e é isso que eu proponho dentro da
arquitetura eu pretendo olhar para o
passado e descobrir os valores que
faltam na vitória de hoje pode ser que
seja muito pretensioso mas é humilde
meio de traços caminho de volta às
minhas origens e tenta trazer para
tudo que eu faço os valores perdidos e
desgastados por uma neocolonização que é
o que a gente só são mais ou menos hoje
em dia eu não tenho muito material para
mostrar mas ter um gostaria de falar
sobre memória sobre identidade sobre e
delicadezas atividade na saudade não
corria até saudade é bom disse que
também às vezes dói mas é bom sentir que
eu tenho certeza que nesse passado que
vocês têm de cantar usá as cidades por
onde vocês passado quer ser de 81 quer
seja um passado rural é proveniente das
origens de você você não encontra
encontrar lembranças que são saudáveis e
que são mantidas como tempo de um
relicário são demônios que vem a última
viagem foi feita pra casa de uma vôo é
ou a casa de um tio durante as férias
normalmente essas casas
conte uma história uma alma que
impregnou em nossas vidas de nossas
vivências um perfume em uma roma
sabe uma uma com o sentimento e atrás
dessa matéria prima voltou atrás
então eu convoco todos a
mergulhar um pouco nesse passado e
tentar descobrir se falou diz que
normalmente nós perdemos
ao construir a arquitetura de hoje na
verdade não só a arquitetura que tudo é
mais um produto da da unidade mas a
gente perder o entre as nossas relações
eu vi como falar ano como arquiteto que
a gente precisa olhar a praticidade é e
ver que a cidade no caso teresina anda
muito mal cuidada planta muito disputada
nós temos um
tudo maravilhosamente verde e que
desrespeitosamente tem afetado as nossas
vidas como esse enorme evolução de calor
nós estamos criando
teresina é uma cidade geograficamente
muito bem posicionada com velocidade
mesmo com o time ganhando por dois gols
de diferença
é é comum que estava em sua sala
perícias e é assim vôo ou a cor da
população os nossos dias quentes e crie
no centro por exemplo aquilo acreditamos
que está acostumado a lidar com a cidade
compacta disso o maior culpado disso
somos nós com as nossas acções que
desmatamos desenfreadamente amigas que
ele e final daquela mangueira do fundo
do nosso quintal
e aí a gente vê faladas na previsão
precisa ser magra
a gente não pode ver com cidade onde as
gravações é existentes são de óleo as
pessoas falam de 93 e com o seu calor ou
outra a gente não pode virar
achei final nos falou de uma outra
maneira
então assim o que o mesmo interesse em
se não convenceu falta de interesse na
cidade verde ele não é considerado feito
há muitos anunciar alguém desse tipo mas
é é isso o que há meses o presidente
consegue manter como se fosse uma
medalha no peito não se esquece de ver
com relações dele o problema trazendo
para terezinha é é um tempo
desconfortáveis nós sentimos na vela com
o passar dos anos o aumento da
temperatura e isso está ligado
diretamente relações há tropas o homem é
o responsável por isso e o que eu tô
aqui pra falar da prefeitura de que
maneira a gente pode diminuir isso a
gente pode diminuir isso é tão legal
a cidade criou um espaço oferecendo para
ser usuária 89 que é uma área de
proteção da floresta de mata atlântica
amazônia que se casavam exatamente no
piauí
o piauí é um
o mundo diferente de todos os outros que
você pode encontrar aqui na da
biodiversidade do piauí é diferente nós
temos a catimba e nós temos o senado que
são biomas não encontrado em nenhum
outro lugar do mundo isso torna o pior
que valoroso quero falar desse olhar em
especial de você deixar de olhar para o
que é de fora e encontrar dentro o que é
específico que é original porque são seu
e valorizar a partir disso então é
porque eu tenho que desmata essa mata
que futuramente pode crescer o nosso o
nosso pulmão verde com o nosso ar
condicionado natural porque é que as
empresas que se preocupam em fazer os
condomínios fechados não se preocupam
mais com a natureza porque na espanha em
algum momento o homem perdeu e será uma
natureza eu proponho uma um retorno ao
selvagem um retorno com o de um homem
poderia viver mais em paz e respeitasse
mais a natureza e eu quero chegar a isso
de uma maneira até muito romântica
trazendo na arquitetura dentro das
cidades
é importante que a gente aprenda a viver
em comunhão com a cidade e com o meio
ambiente que envolve ela é a nossa
cidade
hoje nós temos condomínios de alto luxo
espalhados em motivo de crítica a gente
vai receber porque nós estamos trilhando
caminhos que os países já descobriram
que não são mais os caminhos corretos
os valores estão mudando para
estão quebrando ea gente vem falar de
arquitetura sustentável na cidade que
imprimia é é uma cultura que não é nossa
gente planta uma um dinheiro na nossa
fachada quando a gente tem uma carnaúba
como é que cidades como é que eu posso
construir e como é que eu posso pensar é
no mundo melhor
se nenhum essas estações no olhar
comentou possam enxergar dentro da
cidade o livro como eu posso contribuir
dentro dessa cidade quer ser concorrente
interno que seja como médico como
jornalista eu vejo pessoas das mais
diversas áreas se preocupando precisa de
sistemas
não é porque eles sejam o tempo está na
moda mas eu acredito que já você pode
anunciar uma quebra nessa engrenagem
disse que esse paradigma que a gente
aprendeu a ouvir como certo o que a
globo tipo desde o começo que você tem
que ser assim
então assim a gente está conversando
havendo um novo novo horizonte graças a
deus eu espero me surpreende muito
voltar aqui é empresários o processo
em outros segmentos me procurarem sem
áudio
a gente quer uma no jardim e não é uma
casa com o shakhtar tinha mas queremos
jardim palma casa
uma outra cliente de parnaíba chegou e
disse algo que nós queremos uma casa que
seja um é único que eu possa me
encontrar com a terra e nós fizemos o
projeto nos tornar o seu entender o que
eu quero encontrar com a terra
eu quero aqui top que é tocar nas
paredes de terra tocar no chão de terra
então você vai vendo que aos poucos as
pessoas começam a voltar o olhar ea
gente se encontra lá para aquelas casas
da infância da gente de paredes largas e
grandes listas para o jardim interno
herança dos portugueses dos mouros e ver
que a vida de um modelo talvez cafona ou
da tattoo foi o mais difícil na vá
porque havia uma preocupação com a
distância entre o ser humano e um de
direito é entre os habitantes e o pé
direito daquela casa levando para o alto
calor que entrava então é lá na nossa
colonização pra cá muita coisa boa se
perdeu e eu acredito que com arquitetura
sustentável a gente possa minimizar
ondas de calor
essas ilhas de calor de teresina que
está construindo o retorno dela é
a gente tem uma cliente que chegou pra
gente se olha eu quero uma casa já digo
eu não quero viver numa casa quero uma
casa já que tinga ea gente fez essa casa
tiver essa cliente porque a gente
premiou todas as soluções sustentáveis
que chegam pra gente aqui graças a deus
a gente vive na itália pouco conversava
com o ney e e eu dizia pra ele eu ficava
surpreso que teresina é é a gente pode
viver realmente a gente está bem
adiantado nesses processos que algumas
coisas são atingidas muito facilmente
você vai ter uma casa 100% sustentável é
com soluções que tragam conforto tenha o
conforto legislação pesada é energias
bonitas reuso de água tudo isso não é
mais um sonho e eu acredito que com a
arquitetura que a gente tenta
desenvolver velocidade um dia a gente
possa transformar teresina uma cidade um
pouco mais humana e menos quente mais
amável mas as pessoas são infectadas mas
elas esquecem que a prova de tudo isso
são elas porque elas se relacionam ao
com a cidade elas trafegam ao domínio do
estado see têm uma árvore
com um pouquinho tem que se faz portal
no trato um pouquinho e aí a gente vai
tendo vai perder a cidade está ficando
cada ano mais quente mais insuportável
nós temos diferenças de temperatura de
um a dois graus do centro pra casa na
zona leste só por conta da divisão do
rio
e isso poderia ser potencializado por
isso podem ser aumentados nós poderíamos
ter uma teresina muito melhor mas a
gente precisa despertar a isso para
entender é que o universo resultado
devendo esses modelos estão fadadas a
desaparecer
a gente precisa colocar a maneira de
olhar para a cidade sem mais afetuoso
mais carinhoso com a cidade existem em
lugares aqui em teresina e 13 parques
trenzinho uma cidade praticamente com
três packs a de cabana
o papa que lá das lagoas do norte quando
nós poderíamos ter isso muito mais
existe uma falta de atenção a qualquer
cuidado para com a cidade e eu acredito
muito que a gente esteja no início o
tanto um pouco o rumo dessa dessa
história e eu queria finalizar é
mostrando a a vocês
o movimento implantado o movimento
potável
o movimento de autoria do nosso
escritório que ouvir simples não é
burocrático não é nada é uma coisa você
se responsabiliza pelo mapa durante dois
anos o período em que ela precisa para
se desenvolver com saúde é esse esse
movimento pretende é ampliar e criar uma
rede de dever e de privacidade
nós temos inúmeras espécies que são
adaptadas e climatizada sessão porque
são nossas não preciso lutar com uma com
o que eu não preciso lutar com espécies
de flora enterrados nativas de mensah
beleza basta ver se age branco que está
aqui na nossa porta
então é esse movimento plantar que vem
dia cada um de vocês que plantem
magnitude dela não muito distante de
você pra não dar trabalho eu tenho
certeza que em dois anos vocês não está
encantado com esse movimento e vão
plantar uma segunda água e depois uma
terceira que depois mais com a luta
então com vocês
isso tudo bem
[Música]
[Aplausos]